be seated after two years in detention
Hashim thought she was in court to face
charges of war crimes and crimes against
humanity
I understand the indictment and I'm
fully not guilty that she and his three
co-accused were all senior figures in
the Kosovo Liberation Army and later
prominent politicians they're charged
with 10 counts of persecution torture
murder and forced disappearance of
opponents and alleged pro-serbian
collaborators the indictment charges and
we intend to prove hundreds of
detentions across Kosovo
usually under terrible conditions of
abuse
and over a hundred murders
most of the victims of the accused were
fellow kosovar albanians
the Kosovo Liberation Army launched a
guerrilla war against Serbian rule in
1998 Serbian attacks on Kosovo Albanian
civilians prompted intervention by NATO
forces and an end to fighting in 1999.
five senior Serbian officials were
convicted of war crimes in 2009 but the
former president Milan milotunovich was
acquitted his predecessor Slobodan
milosevic had already died in custody
that she went from military leader to
the Prime Minister who declared kosovan
independence in 2008 Joe Biden called
him his nation's George Washington
but in 2020 now president that she was
indicted he resigned and was extradited
to the Netherlands vowing to clear his
name
Tachi and his co-accused argue they had
nothing to do with crimes carried out by
others in a decentralized guerrilla
Force what is he running from
what is he trying to hide
[Music]
that she supporters rallied outside the
court many kosovans watching back home
accused of anti-kla bias would you call
it you Everton it's not only the just
War of the KLA that's being judged the
state of Kosovo is also on trial they
are not only condemning these people but
they are condemning the effort the war
that the whole world supported
what's not in dispute is that this trial
will be lengthy the prosecution says it
needs two years just to set out its case
Harry Fawcett Al Jazeera
Andrea Lorenzo capusale earlier headed
the economics unit of the international
civilian office in Kosovo he says the
conclusion of a report by the Council of
Europe formed the basis for the trial
ending a two-decade delay
the reason why it took two decades to to
begin this trial is given in the report
which is a basis for this trial it is a
council of Europe report published first
in 2010 and then approved in 2011 by a
Swiss Senator and this report
summarizes ample alleged evidence of the
war crimes and also the violent methods
by which the former KLA leaders later
use their military power to gain
political and economic power in Kosovo
there is a this report summarizes this
evidence and says that the impunity of
these people is explained
by the elimination and intimidation of
Witnesses on one hand and by the fact
that Western Powers decided not to act
upon the evidence overwhelming he says
overwhelming evidence of the war crimes
of these Guerrilla leaders this is what
the report says and the report is in in
fact the basis for this trial so there
is a there is also there are also some
political choices made by Western Powers
those who were in charge of the the
Reconstruction of course after the war